foreign
Houston hey Andre how are you
good how are you better than we deserve
how can we help
um so I've just started your University
and I've got all the materials I'm kind
of thinking a little bit ahead and I was
contemplating what to do with the two
cars I have
okay um basically they're both upside
down big time but I mean in the perfect
world I was about to sell them both and
get a really cheap minivan that I can
fit my five kids what do you owe on the
first one
it's 37
and what's it worth
um well one place one dealership called
me said that they could pay 40 grand for
it but then the car backs and Max
whatever was saying like 30 like really
low 30s
okay well what's the other one yeah
it's the truck
um it's 47 on that one and um it's
definitely I could I know I can only get
like 30 probably 30 mid 30 for it okay
the Traverse is upgraded but the truck
isn't it's just the average
Dodge Ram okay so have you let's do a
little bit more research on this first
car and find out if you can really get
40 for it because if you can are you
looking at to just you're going down to
a one-car family or you
because you could take
the 3000 if you if it really is worth 40
put it towards a 47 and keep rolling or
if you're if you were wanting to sell
both at least that 3000 could go towards
the amount that you're upside down in
car number two
yeah well that's that's Dave's next
question is do you have any money set
aside whatsoever
no that's literally the plan so
um I have to still save the Thousand
emergency
um I've been I'm credit cards are
starting to get paid down and I plan to
cut the first one this next week and so
I'm kind of
still thinking ahead though because I
want to attack this pretty um intensive
so your plan was to sell both cars what
was your plan after that I guess I'm
trying to get on your train of thought
because I can tell you what I would do
but
you're gonna sell something to sell yeah
sell both and get cash for a car like a
minivan that I can fit all if I have
kids okay and then uh what does your
husband Drive
I'm divorced you're divorced oh so you
own two cars with one driver
great oh okay and what's your household
it was like
okay
um right now
um I'm the self-employed business owner
and so after business expense and my cut
basically after employees it's um 120 a
year good I feel myself okay good
so you're you're on it I love your
intensity thank you thank you thank you
that you're going to go places you're
going to be okay so
um well do you how how bad is your
credit
um it was close to 740 now it's down to
a 650 because I've chosen to pay other
stuff rather than credit cards
um
do you have uh who's the truck loan with
who do you owe the money on the truck to
Wells Fargo so it's a good bank and it's
a good interest rate
no it's not a good thing but it is a
bank yeah it's not a bank that's going
broke but um okay so what I would do is
Trot over to is Wells Fargo got a branch
there that you work with
um I kind of ordered the car online so I
mean I could look for a branch of nearby
what I want to do is talk Wells Fargo
and I would prefer to do it in person
talk Wells Fargo into letting you sign a
note for whatever the truck doesn't
bring
so that approximately twenty thousand
dollars or so hopefully you can get more
than thirty for it hopefully your your
data is wrong and you get into KBB and
you do a private sale and you get 35 or
37 then you're only 10 in the hole Yeah
but you would borrow that 10 from Wells
Fargo and uh then they would release the
title to the buyer because you've got to
sign a note for the difference in other
words they're making you the equivalent
of a personal loan which they already
have they're just admitting it okay
because the truck's not worth enough to
cover in the event of a repo so they're
already not they already don't have
sufficient collateral and they're just
allowing you to get rid of the debt
which ensures that you're actually going
to pay the 10 or the 12 or the 15 or
whatever the difference is so that's
what I want to start with is try to get
them to cover let you sign a note for
the difference how much other debt other
than cars do you have
credit cards personal loans and how much
on student loan which
um how much credit card so the credit
cards is probably totaling about 10
grand left to pay good personal loan is
about 10 grand as well because I have
two they're small perfect
um and then the student loan used to be
20 000 now it's 9 000. okay so I feed
that down okay so what I want to
temporarily stop paying on the student
loan completely who's the personal loans
with
personality essentially companies called
opportune and reprise they were
basically when
um because I have four months with my
work and so I didn't have emergency
savings or any kind of Bill savings
until I got personal loans out
okay I'm just wondering if they would
loan you the money to get out of that
car if Wells Fargo won't
pay it off they would
no I'm not talking about if you pay it
off I'm talking about the ten thousand
dollar hole the difference 15 or whole
you're in on the truck oh I'm trying to
get rid of that truck today and you've
got to give Wells Fargo forty seven
thousand dollars to get the title to
that truck to sell it in order to do
that you've got to cover the difference
the amount you're in the hole if Wells
Fargo won't let you sign a note for the
difference you've got to find another
bank or credit union you need to loan
you that that's why I was fishing around
for so okay now yeah I'm selling selling
both of them if I can find a way to
cover the truck deficit by borrowing
that amount and then you're going to uh
that's going to get rid of way more than
half of your debt uh and yeah scrape
together the cash with the difference on
the van and whatever other cash you if
you have to stop uh debt snowballing for
a minute and uh get you a five thousand
dollar van yeah right I hope you can get
five more for the van than it's worth
and then you can just go get a five
thousand dollar van then we can get the
truck sold that's going to leave you 10
or 15 in the hole then you've got 10 on
credit cards 10 on personal loans and 20
on or nine on student loans left so you
know you're going to be out of debt
really really fast with your intensity
and your intentionality you're really
doing good really good that's exciting
I'm excited it's not even my situation
yeah she's really taking action let me
tell you what when you start saying
I'll do whatever it takes and you mean
it yep for towards any goal you're going
to get to go yeah well she's you can
tell she didn't say what it was but
she's got a reason and it's it's very
clear what her reason is and why she's
got to do this and why she's got to act
so intensely and that's really the
difference between her and somebody who
calls in you know lollygagging through
this thing yeah it's
probably pretty easy to surmise a
stinking truck was her exes heck yeah oh
yeah so that thing is there's a lot of
reasons to be pissed with that truck but
the uh yeah getting rid of that and wow
and then cleaning up this mess with your
120 000 income in one year you're going
to be in such a different place because
you're willing to amputate these
vehicles where you're willing to get rid
of them and so you got to set up the
deficit you got to cover that deficit
and then you're going to be fine